(audience applauds)
It's thrifty week!
And I believe that cooking delicious meals for your family
doesn't have to be complicated or expensive.
This is very personal for me and I'm very
passionate about it.
Because as much as we love food here at the show,
I'm very into the realities of families
that work hard and need to put food on the table
for an economical price and quickly.
So for me, I was thinking about, "Okay, sometimes I like
the less is more approach in the kitchen."
The, "How do I have a reality meal
that's also like really amazing?"
Less ingredients, less money, less time.
And I have a quick and simple one
that parents will like as well as kids.
So I'm already dripping everywhere.
So you wanna take...
The best part is there's only three ingredients.
This cost $12 and it feeds four people and it takes minutes.
So this to me is a great reality dinner.
And it's my version of tortellini en brodo!
Which is really just a fancy name for tortellini in broth.
All right, let's get started.
All you need is three ingredients.
Start with any stock that is your personal favorite.
I think it tastes best with a chicken.
But if you're vegetarian, this actually whole meal
can be vegetarian.
But we're going with chicken today.
So it says you know, on the package, I think we went
with a Buitoni for this.
They say about seven minutes, I like it a little
on the al dente side.
You'll put in this amount and it's gonna like bulk up.
And then all of a sudden you're gonna have like kind of
twice the amount so don't be surprised by that.
Then once it's all finished, which this is still cooking.
I'm gonna go to this bowl here.
You wanna take it and you wanna...
I like a little cracked pepper and Parmesan cheese.
I mean it's really this simple, broth, pasta in,
wait a few minutes, ladle it into your bowl
and then if it's just for your kids, that's it.
Simple, tortellini and broth.
But if you're an adult and you have adult palette like me,
you need that amazing umami and you want a great,
fresh Parmesan cheese.
Now this is the most expensive item in the entire meal,
the fresh block of Parmesan.
And I think it is worth spending the money.
But you can also, I do love me
that skinny, long canister any day of the week.
(audience laughs)
So, that's it!
That's all there was to this beautiful, simple meal
that is so delicious, I cannot wait
to get my mouth around it.
(spoon clatters)
That really didn't sound right. (chuckles)
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
(Drew chuckles)
(audience laughs)
(spoon clatters)
(audience cheers and applauds)
(Drew chuckles)
Ross, come try this.
Hi, hi, hi!
(audience cheers and applauds)
I smelled it backstage!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I gotta...
Ready?
(spoon clinks)
What?
Drew, that's amazing!
(audience applauds)
It's so simple!
Mmm, it's all about the Parmesan.
Oh, that's so delish.
I really don't feel like this needs any salt.
You're gonna get the salt from inside
the cheese in the tortellini.
And you're gonna get the salt from the Parmesan
that's grated on there.
So here's my suggestion for a simple, affordable,
beautiful, lovely meal that works for everybody.
This tastes like a million dollars.
Thank you, Drew.
Really?
Oh, thank you, Rossy!
Mmm, oh!
(audience applauds)
I'm gonna eat the whole thing!
By the way, I'm on a cleanse right now, Ross, by the way.
How's that going?
Not great.
Yeah. (chuckles)
I hope you like this recipe.
(Ross and audience laugh)
Yeah, I wrote a cookbook, Ross.
Say that again?
I wrote a cookbook.
You did?
Yeah.
It's called "Rebel Homemaker".
Oh, so proud of you.
Because I looked up the definition of homemaker
and I was furious.
What did it say?
It's so antiquated.
Oh no, well that's why you're a rebel, Drew.
Well, I thought if I put the word rebel in front of it,
we might get somewhere.
So that book is gonna be out and available.
And it has cost-effective meals, just like this.
I can't wait, is this one in it?
No.
Oh well, they don't need it!
You just showed 'em!
(audience laughs)
(upbeat music)